the coronavirus is pushing many
hospitals to their breaking point and
the vaccination effort
is under pressure as well people who
wanted to get the vaccine lined up in
texas yesterday and many counties there
are now
out of the vaccine one hospital in
northern california had to move very
fast
to give out hundreds of doses that
started thawing out after a power
failure there
our lead national correspondent david
begne was in los angeles
where the ambulances have been told not
to transport the patients
with virtually no chance of survival boy
david i heard that and thought you would
hate to be the patient
that needs to get to the hospital until
nope we're not taking you good morning
to you
think about that gail good morning to
you that's what it's come to they're now
telling these ambulance drivers don't
even bring them
if they don't have a chance of survival
don't even transport them
here la county is arguably the epicenter
of the country when it comes to covid
and martin luther king jr community
hospital where we are in south l.a is
the epicenter in the epicenter let me
tell you this
they have 134 licensed beds that's what
they have approval for
you know how many covet patients they
have as of this morning 164.
sean take take that live picture if you
will we put a camera in the meditation
room of the hospital this morning
with their permission of course because
they have no space left
they're using this to treat people who
don't even have covet
they are out of room they're using
corners and the chapel
and the gift shop in the meditation room
because they are out of place
uh places to put patients yet the
ambulances keep showing up
look at the lines to get tested in
california
and to get vaccinated in florida these
are pictures of a pandemic spiraling out
of control
in most corners of the country there are
more than 4 million seniors living in
florida and they are overwhelming
registration websites
and hotlines in a rush to get immunized
we were here two and a half hours early
because we figured it was going to be
a showdown but the state of florida has
administered less than 25 percent of the
doses
it already received facing criticism for
the slow pace
governor ron desantis issued this
warning hospitals that do not
do a good job of getting the vaccine out
will have their allocations
transferred to hospitals that are doing
a good
giving half doses of the modern vaccine
to those between the ages of 18 and 55
but new this morning fda commissioner
stephen hahn cautioned against that
writing in a statement suggesting
changes to the fda authorized dosing
is premature and not rooted solidly in
the available science
there's a fundamental concept here take
as directed
that is dr tom friedman he's the former
director of the centers for disease
control and prevention
he says the first way to speed up things
is for the government to ship
all available vaccines instead of
holding half
in a reserve for second dosing let's get
the vaccine out get
first doses into people as the second
doses are coming along
that's not saying let's change the
regimen back here in los angeles county
where we are one person dies from covid
every 15 minutes marisa black is a nurse
at henry mayo hall hospital in valencia
where the number of coveted patients
jumped from 15 at the end of october
to nearly 100 today she's worried about
the quality of care
as doctors and nurses are being forced
to take on more patients
this patient needs pain medication this
patient's oxygen level is dropping
and this other patient now is needs to
go to the bathroom
if you cut our time short what will we
need to cut short
let's talk about this new variant of the
coronavirus it's believed to be more
contagious but not more deadly there are
six variant cases here in california
one discovered as of yesterday in new
york state and anthony the variant first
popped up in the uk and as you know they
have now gone back into full lockdown in
the united kingdom yep at it again david
thank you